lorsque les gens appris hier qu'ils
avaient la plus grosse des émeutes sont
apparus l'anarchie s'est mise en place
les gens n'avaient plus de raison de
vivre jusqu'au jour où jean michel calme
le game arriva il fit un discours
instaurant une nouvelle question dans la
tête des gens qu'elle youtuber elle vaut
la vie a repris son cours
les émeutes ces serres du moins jusqu'à
ce que quelqu'un réponde à cette
question
ok ok c'est notre bien épique pour un
quiz un peu pété quand même à
aujourd'hui nous sommes surtout pitot
points comme voilà il ya françois qui a
publié hier hommage dans ces deux vidéos
à quiz pour savoir quel youtuber nous
sommes les chaînes youtube et youtuber
pullulent sur internet depuis quelques
années et on est sûr à 59% que tu es
abonné à plus de dix chaînes bon
peut-être mais taratra n'êtes pas
tension et comme tu rêve secrètement de
devenir youtuber de qualité on te
propose un joli quiz offrant la
possibilité de savoir quelles
personnalités de l'internet eut est
question petit homme à temps soit en
cours d'histoire quel est le premier
site que tu visites lorsque tu te rends
sur l'internet facebook twitter youtube
skyblog u-boot hôpitaux
twitter etc ce qui a pesé dans la nuit
je me renseigne et touche comme ça
devant les drames à habas et clash le
voit la question de petits c'est comment
david tu sur le world wide web avec ta
souris tel un bg avec ton pattes comme
un galet rien avec ton pouce à l'e pl1
l'adn de bar de métro une excellente
question l'ex femme
moi je suis un gros beauf mais avec ta
souris tel un bg ou alors avec le pad sa
dépense dépens et c'est une fois sur 2 6
me si je vais ce pc portable ou par le
vent raconte ma vie on s'en fout mais
enfin c'est important de dire à l'issue
de ce quiz le monde changera [ __ ] bon
allez on va sur une question 3 petit cul
je parle pas du tiens quel secret
l'internet souhaites-tu découvrir le
moyen d'agrandir sa [ __ ] en seulement
trois semaines
alors ça c'était le cas quand vous venez
de voir la [ __ ] de la sptr baleines dans
la vidéo d'avant là après une bonne nuit
ce sera mieux rencontrer les meufs
chaude dans un région parfois juste
cliquer sur l'espagne qui monte comment
faire trouver un remède simple contre
l'acné et ebola et que les médecins se
détestent
il prend par les sentiments percer la
manière de gagner 3000 euros par mois en
restant chez toi bah ça il faut juste
faire des vidéos de mer sur youtube du
coup je veux trouver un remède simple
contre l'acné niveau là voilà quatre
petits afca lettons ont préféré parmi
cette liste non exhaustive de si
nombreux 1 2-10 1 85 9 2 603 5,9 savons
donc préféré [ __ ] l'infini ou l'infini
+1 moi j'aime bien l'infini plus simple
que celle insolence à l'état pur ah
ouais machin c'est infini bah moi c'est
infini plus a fini plus tôt car tiger
ferme ta gueule infinie +1 quelle est ta
position favorite debout assise allongé
au blick le 69 c'est le cesc dans le
sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
j'avoue bien aimé la position oblique
leur vraiment comme ça en plus après
j'avoue des fois je dors dans le sens
inverse des aiguilles d'une montre du
coucher parquet rouette cacahuètes
elle assouplit question si ce parti deux
petits z droitiers ou gauchers ou chauve
gauche et chez hugo chavez gauche et rp
z la gauche toi même poussé au nom
[Musique]
c'est bien j'arrête ma chaîne youtube
question 7 as-tu déjà brûlé un pote
même juste pour le fun au plus grand des
calmes
mais tous les matins avant de faire des
vidéos pourquoi je suis en forme à ton
avis belge branle un pote [ __ ] je me
semble qu'elle cuisson la viande bleue
saignante à points bien cuite pas de
cuisson la mie tu me foule c'est un mode
tartare non merci je ne mange pas de
viande
en revanche je vais vous prendre des
cailloux c'est bon les cailloux j'ai des
doutes sur cette dernière blague mais
s'éloigne pas mal question 9 manger une
banane par le haut ou par le bas par le
haut ou par le bas
sérieux même finalement et ses
entraînements tout loupé fdp françois
par le haut bien sûr c'est bien plus
simple chapitre 4 questions dix petits
c'est qu'elle
on en a marre qu'elle poutre mérite le
plus d'abonnés au [ __ ] la poutre
mélomanes sur les heures de pointe
la poutre monoxyde de carbone la poutre
agissant durablement sur l'environnement
la poutre alourdi par le poids des
remords la poutre qui a vu ses actions
grimper en bourse de 4 % ou la poutre
dérangé par son voisin au petit matin
car ce fumier fait des travaux chez lui
c'est la seule à ce fils de [ __ ] qui
fait des travaux là de temps en temps le
matin au caire où se tient c'est l'heure
des résultats qu'elles youtuber vais-je
être tué cyprien
je suis juste schizophrène depuis tout
ce temps il n'y avait en fait qu'une
seule personne sur le canapé de super
gaming
[Musique]
un wagon du coup je suis calme plus
d'abonnés en france et qui avait
particulièrement riche friqués et
possédant une somme d'argent allant bien
au delà de 16 euros c'est vrai de plus
tu es célèbre dans le monde entier
puisque brad pitt et obama et tout le
monde est ton corps afin de le palper
régulièrement les gens parlent peu
cyprien c'est vrai chez toi tu détiens
deux fusées un hélicoptère est une
machine à coudre
je suis pas sûr pour la machine à coudre
ouais ben jaffar cette vidéo sur ce quiz
complètement teubé merci françois
n'était pas mendoça vous a plu on a bien
rigolé oh ça va plus simple j'ai plus de
questions quittera dans ma tête je